I remember when we were doing a Survivor
sketch okay and you were playing
[Laughter]
or it's like do you think Jeff Probst
was actually on the show right yeah and
we're you guys are like sitting around
like the logs with the fire you know and
you said something and I remember like
they go how do you know and you go
ancient Chinese secret and you you you
bow and back back up and you fall as you
roll over
and you stand up and then afterwards you
go I I took a [__] in my skirt when it
happened I actually [__] a little bit in
my skirt when I fell
would you go ancient Chinese for Connie
jump It's Korean
wait what
um
[__] was that live or I was alive yeah
that was a live one baby what are your
memories of it though I mean do you do
you look back on it and you're like
um in in in in in in a positive way or
yeah I think yeah more or less you know
I yes at this point now I do I was you
know they let me go like I did five yeah
I did five years and then like I was
expecting to come back and I'm so
embarrassing I remember like I was with
my wife on like a little vacation I was
like I said to her like if they don't
pay me you know x amount of dollars I'm
not coming back and my manager called me
and goes so their offers nothing and so
I was they like what yeah I did not even
know that yeah they brought everyone
else back I think they were they knew
the show was over because you guys did
like another year out oh yeah oh my God
that was a grim year I think it was they
were circling the drain a little bit and
I figured they were like we don't need
him but I was sad because you and Jordan
and Keegan were still there yeah and so
I was bummed and then when I was there
like I wish I could go back now and say
to myself like don't stress about this
like I remember being stressed because I
was like this could be the best sketch
show on TV like I felt like I was in
Aaron Sorkin show where I was like God
damn it it's important to me you know
what I mean this sketch where I'm
playing the dad on Frasier it's
important to me yeah yeah and
um so I I remember like just being like
frustrated I was always I was always
like we should not be trying to be like
SNL and like SNL at that time was I
think the best SNL ever it was a great
Will Ferrell and Amy Poehler and Bill
Hader and Tina it was just like the the
best ever yeah and so us trying to like
have guests uh most of our guests work
on online but we would have I mean
earlier the earlier years we would get
like like Ryan Reynolds did it yeah but
it was it was Ryan Reynolds like
10 years before Deadpool came out like
we got and I remember he was so cool and
nice yeah it was awesome he did it and I
thought it was cool but it was like at
the time yeah we would be like oh we're
we're getting this wrestler who's kind
of popular right now and then SNL would
be like oh there's a sketch where like
Paul McCartney is like blowing Steve
Martin you know what I mean yeah it's
like what are we doing yeah like why are
we playing a game I always thought yeah
but but it was still like I should have
just
be working harder and doing better
sketches these sketches are bad so I
should have just shut the [__] up did
you feel that because I remember like
after mad was over I would see you at
auditions and stuff right and we would
like be so happy to see each other but I
felt that
um the last
I mean the the first five years of
believing mad was pretty Grim for me it
was a three years for me about three and
a half years and it was the worst time I
had in LA and Hollywood yeah because uh
first of all I was like well Mad TV's
over I'll just get my own pilot
and like people were like oh no we hate
you hey we don't [__] give a [__]
about you yeah it was it was it was
actually an embarrassing thing people
would you would people go oh he's from
Mad TV like it was a negative absolutely
at the time yes yes not learned is that
younger people I think do have more of
an appreciation for it like I I don't
know this might be anecdotal but do I go
to Canada I go to Canada I'm Elvis dude
I am they love it
I go to
uh like Magic Mountain I I am Taylor
Swift I am [__] Taylor Taylor Swift
yeah yeah and I always love oh my God I
told I think I told you guys the story
of how there was a guy you guys were
like shooting with who's like a wrestler
who's a comic
Brendan's job Brendan a wrestler yeah
he's a fighter a fighter and I I had
never heard of any of this but a Lyft
driver I took this Lyft driver one night
pick me up that's [__] funny funniest
dude I've ever met in my life I get and
he's like what's up man
I like doing that like holy [__] I can't
believe it's not I was like oh what's up
man he's like yo yo yo I was raised I'm
at TV I was [__] raped just [__]
super excited about Mad TV yeah so we're
driving uh he pulls out what I thought
was like a flute at first then I
realized it was a [__] Vape gun
and he [__] filled the car yeah he
took a hit and rolled down the window
but blew it like in the car and it was
like it was like if like uh someone ate
like a thousand raspberries
and he's like yo you know what's going
on with Bobby Lee and I was like no he
said oh man he's in this [__] fight
with this guy
and he was telling me the story in
pieces he's like and this guy man this
guy accused him a [__] lion
he's telling me the story like while
he's going like 70 down a residential
neighborhood and he's not used in the
rear view mirror yeah he's like and this
guy's not even real comic I mean
five years ago because he was like Joe
Rogan guy he's like you like Joe Rogan I
was like I don't know he's like yeah
well Bobby leaving him he wants to
[__] body me and he's gonna go on the
show
it was like this guy gave me this
[__] it was amazing I saw you guys
shortly afterwards I saw you at uh the
premiere of note oh
yeah yeah yeah you know dude when I saw
you then we were watching
um I just I mean how proud of you I mean
I I looked at Jordan I was like I can't
[__] believe it it's amazing I
believe it right but it's just like
there's